[Music]
do you guys have
any socially unacceptable things that
you think should be normalized
i'll give you an example nose picking
should be normalized i think my entire
existence should be okay
but people are fine people find problems
with it
with your existence yeah like the entire
society is like [ __ ] parts exist like
you know when i walk outside of my
underwear
people think it's weird so you think
that that's one okay right
stuff like that right that should be
normal like there's i don't know i feel
like there's a lot of things that i do
that uh there is a movement going around
because girls are like
how come this lingerie is not okay
but this bikini is okay and then it's
like covering up the same
parts yeah i think they're both okay i
think but that's what bart's doing
yeah he's like how come these shorts are
okay
but these boxer underwears are not okay
it covers up the same part it's the same
thing yeah cause i feel like the
majority of the world
probably views me as eccentric
but i don't think i'm eccentric i think
i'm normal well none of us do so i want
to be normalized
okay but does that make sense yeah true
as the most
normal person here i would like to say
that
the world is crazy not me
yeah i believe that you have axes on the
table in front of you
that should be normalized too right and
you know what that should be normalized
too nobody's saying it's normal
yeah that's what normalizing is yeah i
guess they're not sharp
what's wrong with having an axe we're
gonna be wearing glasses so you're gonna
we're gonna hit with it
my [ __ ] up those glasses is out of frame
this is style glasses dude they don't
work
i legit think that so nose picking is
one of those things where sometimes you
just got a crusty or you got something
going on you gotta get out of there but
you just don't feel right doing it you
just don't you could do it in hong kong
well you could do it if you have tissue
that's actually but isn't that
interesting you could dig all the way up
your nose with a tissue but with your
with your with your finger
everyone's like jesus because we don't
know you're going to wash it and if you
go like this
and then if you flick it they judge even
more i've never done using it in public
what people 2020 bro 20 point [ __ ] that
up
it's a new dude not sneezing into your
elbow
i wish that was more normalized do you
want to sneeze
out yeah i want to be free again that's
gross everybody sees it to their elbows
now and then they touch elbows to say hi
i know bro what's with that
wait no it's a different part of the no
i always touch inner elbows to say hi
hey what's up how about this when you
eat chocolate right and it drops on the
floor and you pick it up and go
oh dude that's it don't wait a handshake
go like this [ __ ] inner elbows dude
what's up dog
is not the swedish way it looks swedish
um that's ikea style wooden shoes that
should be very normal
surprisingly they're not very
comfortable i think oh really i imagine
let's normalize people agreeing with me
on how beautiful i am
you're pretty beautiful i think you're
beautiful i think your loved ones what
is okay i've been struggling with this
all my life okay my dad used to beat me
the [ __ ] up and said why can't you just
be normal
and i was like if you just told me what
the [ __ ] that was
i would do it so you stop [ __ ] me up
right beat me with normal not kane
yeah and then and he's all like just
normal you that's normal and then he
couldn't explain it and he just kept
saying
you're so dumb you don't know what
normal is that sounds like you trying to
explain something
the apple doesn't fall very far from the
tree right no it doesn't so like
but you're not gonna be your kids to be
normal till this day no i'll beat them
for not making money or something yeah
like
it's something normal yeah so like until
this day i don't understand
what this normal is and
to whom so you were beaten for this i
mean what he's saying is easy
because i get it because taika is very
eccentric too
and then so for me to get him to do i
guess quote-unquote normal things that i
see his cousins
easily do which is sit there watch tv
and do nothing
or eat food or do whatever he always
have to do things in his crazy ass way
but i think i'm i'm fortunate enough to
be educated enough to know that okay
this
eccentric kid is made by an eccentric
parent so i know where he's coming from
so there's no way he's ever gonna do
things
easy so i'm not gonna beat his ass for
it but but then i do understand like
when when you see like if there was a
kid that was like me and another kid
that just did the typical normal
when i tell him to sit there for an hour
he's so down to do it i'm like oh i see
why they want it because it's so easy
yeah is that the same with another thing
that i was told is
you need to have common sense commons
yeah same thing they just want their job
to be easier so i'm like
okay your job is to teach
me these whatever these common sense
things are
i don't even know what that is so like
you really don't have common sense then
and it's your parents fault for not
teaching you or yeah that's a
i think it's a lack of knowledge my
friend because i think comment
i operate i think everyone here operates
thinking that they understand what
common sense is right
so if you think something else is common
sense
then that means the two worlds collide
so
you need to do your part and explain
what your world's common sense
is so i get a grasp of your baseline in
reality
and i was i would tell that to my
parents not in those words
and i get really [ __ ] up that's too
smart i get way [ __ ] up they beat me
the [ __ ] up because they're like
you're just trying to be smart with me
and i'm like bro
to them that's meta and they're probably
like you just broke rule number one
would just not be normal yeah
also you broke the fourth wall we don't
know what you're looking at
they hit me so hard i went this way and
i'm looking at the wall that's what
happened
like i could totally see your dad also
like venting to your mom like it's so
[ __ ] easy i give him two rules
normal i have common sense and he's
breaking both of them all [ __ ]
kid thinks he's zach morris talking a
wall i broke my mom in 20
years because she was like you know what
all those [ __ ] that you said when you
was a kid
i knew deep inside i felt stupid because
i didn't know what to say
so my teacher was just putting you in
trouble
because i needed time to think about it
and i would think about what you said
for a week and i realized
that i didn't think very much wow
that's deep though you educated your own
mother did you and did you but it took
her 20 plus years to admit it and
knowing you did you say
i knew i was right yep i rubbed it in
her face
you know what dude i got that's how pity
i am i am petty another because i would
call her up just to hear her cry and be
and admit her fault and i'd be like
that's right it took me 20 years but i'm
a long game player [ __ ]
and i go i love you mom bye it's like
crypto just like his dad
and crypto i don't [ __ ] around dude
anyway i have a list here so we are
petty together yeah
i have a list here just a big long game
things that people
think should be more socially acceptable
and commonly are
deemed as unacceptable so like number
one for example is
not forgiving your family or not
forgiving people who have purposely
wronged or hurt you especially family
i'm really tired of hearing people sleep
wrong do
yes whoa purposefully yes they said
yes i'm really tired of hearing people
say be the bigger person or you have to
forgive your family no matter what
no you don't and it's perfectly fine
breed me too yeah they purposely [ __ ]
you over
yep i don't know why you have to be the
bigger person [ __ ] you i do think
there's a way of
uh forgiving you for your own sake but
then
you say for your family that's not right
that's different but i'm saying in terms
of like
i figured them they don't need to know i
forgave them i moved on i don't need to
speak to them
like i forgot the same was like uh i
forget i forgave
like i want everyone to eat but just a
different table or something
just not on my table you know fool me
once deuces
see your ass in hell i think forgiveness
is more about you
than anything else because when you live
with pain and hate like
you're only killing yourself yeah that's
true yeah but it seems like here it's
kind of like
well you should be the bigger person and
have this person back into your life
[ __ ] no that's so stupid that comes from
a dumb ass who
doesn't understand okay every time you
bring someone new
i mean if you bring this person with
baggage back into your life
you are walking into a trap because
you are you you have you're vulnerable
around this person right
so like let's say it's something like a
parent there's history
you're not strong enough yet to do that
maybe in the future you can when you are
ready
but when people go oh you should be the
big person just let them back in it's
like
why torture yourself it doesn't teach
them as well
by the way jesus never got a second
chance with judas
nope no judas just judased his ass are
these some of your friends
no no no i'm talking about the biblical
jesus although i do know many jesus
so i understand yeah yeah thank you
don't you guys see though too a lot of
people their success would have been way
greater if they didn't
stick around with certain family members
but they feel the obligation to being
with them because they're quote unquote
family do you think loyalty kind of
destroys
a part of a thousand percent because
it's a stupid rule
like for example right why should you be
loyal towards someone
if they continuously been [ __ ] using
you for 15 years or belittling you or
anything else
but then you're like oh i'm still loyal
because we have the same last name
that's my blood
i have to take care of them why like why
they've been using you taking your money
beating you whatever
blood should i mean disrespectful [ __ ]
that well to me i think the key word is
the purpose
on purpose part yeah because that's part
of it there's mal intent so that's
yeah cause it's like joe's mom didn't
even know she was doing it on purpose
she's she knows later on she's like [ __ ]
i really [ __ ] up and i knew i was
[ __ ] up but i didn't know how to say
i was [ __ ]
that's why i don't torture her anymore i
love the [ __ ] out of her dad you torture
me i love torturing him dude he'll ask
me for money and i'll be like hell yeah
i got it
all right i'll call you back in a week
oh i forgot about the money i'll call
you back in a week
make the [ __ ] wait because you know
why he's trying to take advantage of me
so [ __ ] him yeah and i think that's the
way we should roll
like dude yeah all right next one uh so
remember these are things
oh there's a actually a whole list of 35
things that's somebody very patient
we only have 34 more to go we're not
going to do all the worst ones
oh i don't know keep going keep going i
love these yeah okay well
the ones that rhyme with orangutan no so
this one says
um that we should normalize having stds
it says we should all be trying our best
to practice safe sex
yes but stigmatizing stds keeps people
from seeking out help
well sure but nobody wants to get them i
normalize it
not yeah it's not about normalized
getting them it's about
normalized having them who stigmatizes
that who does that oh like you know
socially people be like oh you got
gonorrhea or something look with people
i got chlamydia took some antibiotics
and it went away like that but i think
the idea
the idea sometimes is like hey i don't
want to get that so let's be careful
here
i hope that's not what as like hating on
it
yeah no i think it's like because it's
so stigmatized people who might have an
std won't even go seek out help because
it's just embarrassing so that does suck
yeah
it's like yeah people like i know so
many people that had covered they're
sick as [ __ ]
and they're like no i don't got it
they're like dude you're sick and
they're like
no it's something else yeah i can't
taste [ __ ] i really don't have a dress
yeah i'm like
they're they're too afraid i'm like dude
it's fine yeah you gotta normalize it
should be okay
yeah and then another one that's similar
is like
uh seeking help when you're going to
through like mental health issues right
like i think now it's not as bad as when
we were growing up for example like oh
my god you could never tell anyone you
went to a therapist because they'd look
at you and call you crazy
but now it's it's getting normalized
which is a good thing but it's still on
this list
of like yeah we should definitely
normalize that like not stigmatize it so
much another one is
talking about periods in period pain we
shouldn't have to whisper
like girls is it normalized yeah like
we're talking about something horrible
people without those
things i feel like are normal yeah
people without periods should also
understand why we can't make it
to something during our periods just
don't ask me to buy your tampons yeah
that was funny as [ __ ] i saw all that
[ __ ] was that the one where they would
send
the boyfriend yeah yeah yeah but yeah
another one is um like going to the
cinema alone
you get to pick the movie you get to
pick this next you get to pick the time
i've been through casey right that one
that's that's totally mean he goes all
the time my buddy does this i [ __ ]
shame him for it every time i actually
don't even think it's that weird
i don't think he'll watch this video i
just think it's funny to shame him every
time and if your part of the problem
stephen
yeah but it's just a funny guy yeah you
have to normalize it you know what's
funny though is like
i feel like this keeps happening like
these things that are stigmatized like
in different groups right like
just because you and your family like
went through it
went above it doesn't mean that the
world went too
so like we might have experienced this
in our childhood or whatever there's
still people going through this [ __ ]
that's what i was like oh [ __ ] yeah like
i'm cool with it but damn
some people are still struggling with
this [ __ ] one that stood out to me a lot
um when i was reading this last night
was like there was one that said
something about like
telling your friends i love you
apparently a lot of people don't
and i don't love them i was like oh [ __ ]
that's crazy i love you i love you
i have to say i love you guys i love you
guys i love you guys i started doing
that during the pandemic actually a
buddy of my
my my real bud my super super bud was
going through some [ __ ]
and i get off the phone with him now
every time and i tell him i love him
every time
that's awesome i love that yeah cause
it's like why why be
embarrassed i love all of you guys
dinner but don't [ __ ] me over and you
know what's gonna happen
if i do it to my own parents i'll do it
to you if you're not petty with me
yeah i will be disappointed if i [ __ ]
you over thank you
that's true love that is true though i
like that it took me a second to
piece those no he expects more out of me
yeah if i [ __ ] him over and he's not
petty with me
that's [ __ ] that's [ __ ] that's
true that means he didn't love him
that's true exactly oh the last one
really quick the one that i think you'll
love
joe specifically because you've
expressed how much you love this in the
past
men wearing dresses oh why would i want
that no no you've expressed
how you like wearing a dress can i just
say why did you say
that when he would dress up as a mom
and he would wear the moomoo joe you've
said this a million times you know i say
how frequent
you do you don't say this listen he's
taking it back
he's thinking about it is very
comfortable see what i mean [ __ ]
comfortable
joe's just saying we don't need to go
off a cliff
that's where i draw the line did we not
just negotiate a bunch of terms i mean
come on guys you guys are asking for a
lot here with this one
honestly like yeah so this person wrote
like let men and women wear what they
want and not have gendered clothes yeah
yeah just [ __ ] wear a dress or a
skirt if you're comfortable in it right
now for you listening
you just do it no one's this is never
gonna like all these things
don't tell them what if it's illegal but
if your friends make fun of you that's
still
your fault then be your friend's ass and
be like you're now they're gonna make
fun of him for getting beat up by a guy
in a driveway if your friends don't make
fun of you you don't make fun of your
friends you guys aren't real friends
true
come on once if uh you [ __ ] him over
and he was like you want to see it
that's fine we just remain not friends
this is nothing petty would you be like
damn he didn't love me yeah i'd be so
disappointed so disappointed would you
be more hurt
that you [ __ ] him over he didn't do
anything no i if he if i [ __ ] joe over
big time and he tries to reach out to me
and talk to me or something i'd be like
i'm so disappointed
[Laughter]
who are you even who's reaching out to
me what happened to my old friend joe
that i thought you didn't even know him
the first in the first place yeah i i
don't even know who this guy is who's
trying to reach out to me like
judging them even more yeah big time i
thought i knew you
you